So to illustrate
the importance of covariance,
we're going to take a look at
a couple different stocks here.
These are pretend, of course.
So here's one, ABC, it's gone up 10%.
Here's another stock, GHI,
it's also gone up 10%.
But notice it tends
to zig when ABC zags,
so it's not going in lockstep with ABC.
Finally, here's our last stock
that we'll take a look at, DEF.
Note how it goes almost
in lockstep with ABC.
So, three stocks, two that move together
very similarly, and one that moves
opposite them sometimes, yet
they've all provided about 10% return.
What is the best portfolio
we can build by combining
these three different stocks?
So, let's consider their covariance, or
how they move together, for a moment.
So ABC and DEF move very similarly.
And if we were to measure their
covariance, and this is the covariance
of daily returns, which if you're just
looking at one stock versus another,
that's the same as the correlation
coefficient of their daily returns.
So 0.9 means that they move
very closely to one another.
Now, if we were to look at the
co-variance of daily returns of ABC and
GHI, we would find that they actually
have a negative correlation.
In other words, when ABC goes up,
GHI tends to go down.
So they actually have a negative
correlation, or a negative covariance,
whereas ABC and
DEF have a positive covariance.
Again now, what's the best
way to blend these together?
So let's consider a couple
different portfolios,
which are just weightings
on these different assets.
Let's look first at one that
is 50% ABC and 50% DEF.
So what's that one going to look like?
Well, they both move very similarly, so
this portfolio is going to
track the two of them together.
So the performance of this portfolio
is going to look something like this.
So that's fine, it ends up returning
10%, just like the two major assets that
it holds, but there's no real advantage
in blending these two assets because
it just has the same volatility as
each one of them by themselves.
So what if we try something
a little bit different?
What if we take 25% of ABC, 25% of DEF,
so that's going to give us this same
motion that we saw here when
we combined those two, but,
we put the rest of it in GHI?
So now we're combining an anticorrelated
asset with these other two.
So what's this portfolio
going to look like?
Well, it's going to be a nice
blend of them, with very
low volatility, because when one zigs,
the other zags.
So this portfolio will also have a 10%
return, but look how smooth it is.
And that's because we're blending
anticorrelated assets together.
So we get the same return but lower
volatility than any asset by itself.
So all these assets by themselves
had significant volatility, but
when we put them together,
we reduced volatility significantly.
That's the magic of what
Markowitz provided, and
we'll look a little bit more
at that in just a moment.